if you're gonna borrow money from anyone
whoever would that be the government
when that be the bank never borrow money
to buy something that's not going to be
an asset so what is my interest in to
the help device kids hey my name is
Samuel needs and I did a whole video
about the help to buy scheme which was
the the government scheme and the video
got a very interesting reaction some
people were almost offended because when
I explained the help to buy scheme I
talked about the cons and a lot of the
catches that the government put in place
that people aren't aware of when they go
to buy the house and what those are just
in a nutshell when the government give
you money to buy a property you only put
five percent deposit here but all
they're doing is loaning you the money
but you have to pay it back after five
years interest comes and they say you
have to buy a new build house and buying
a new build house that you have to live
in normally you buy a new build house
straight after you bought it the house
drops and it leaves you in negative
equity very easily so there's a lot of
patches and potential problems with the
help to buy scheme now what people said
was they said Samuel I bought a house on
the help Timaeus game and actually it's
done quite well listen
generally speaking over time properties
go up in value so even if you buy a
house to live in yourself and it's a new
belt and you borrow the government's
money to do it yeah you eat long term
I'm not saying you're going to be
disasterous situation you might do okay
out of it there's also a lot of people
that regretted doing it but here's my
main point because I don't want to just
come and say don't do the government
skip I want to give alternatives as well
so here's the main point if you're going
to borrow money from anyone okay where
would that be the government whether
that be the bank never borrow money to
buy something that's not going to be an
asset now if you're buying a house to
live in unless you rent the rooms out
and a lot sure you're supposed to do
that but that's another thing that some
people said they did do so fair enough
but what the government want is you buy
a house and you live in it if you're
living in it it's not giving you any
money it's actually losing you money
because you're having to pay on the
mortgage on the maintenance so it's not
an asset and when you borrow money
whether it's from the government or from
a bank or wherever it's from to put into
something that's not gonna make you
money you're going to end up having to
pay
interests to the government but it's not
making you any money that's called bad
debt so what is my alternative to the
help to buy scheme my alternative is
rather than borrowing money from the
government which comes with a million
clauses and catches and strings attached
so much so that you're wrapped up your
red tape forced down the route that they
want you to go down is borrow money from
other people or other places where
there's no strings and instead of
investing it in something that you have
to live in it's something that has to be
a new-build investing in something that
makes money that's my alternative so
borrowing money maybe from your friends
and family and put that money into an
actual business or an actual investment
property and then that way as long as
the investment properties making you
good cash flow use part of that cash
flow to pay back the family members
interest and then suddenly you're you
have good debt instead of bad debt and
if you haven't got the deposit to put
down on a house and you can't raise the
money then be creative and being an
entrepreneur and going to make the money
learn about property investments and
package the deals and then pass them on
to investors and charge a fee and while
you're doing that you get really good at
finding properties you're making money
you're learning and earning and then be
a smart investor with it so that would
be my alternative if helped to buy as
help you and you glad you did it then
good for you but my advice is always
don't rely on the government because the
government do not want you to be
financially free the government want to
control you and to control you they need
you poor so rely on it yourself Get
Smart get the knowledge learn to invest
well and learn to raise finance on good
property investments not on things that
are going to be a liability I hope you
find that video helpful if you want to
learn from me and you want to become an
expert property investor I have created
a two-day program called the property
investors crash course I'd love to see
you on the program get booked on and
guess what it is my free gift to you as
well so I do YouTube videos for free
I've written books that I get people for
a I've got a crash course which is
two-day property investment training
which I get for free because my mission
is that you become successful
I don't see anyone as competition I see
everybody as collaboration so your
success is my oxygen get yourself booked
on the property investors crash course
right here it also if you want to watch
me becoming financially free from
scratch you can watch exactly what I did
right over here and of course please
don't forget to subscribe over down
below and turn the notification belt on
get subscribed I'll see you at the crash
course